hannah jones has accepted a five-year
contract with the unc's journalist
school
we reached out to her and have not heard
back the chairman of the unc board of
trustees told cbs
news that the board has taken no action
and made no decision concerning her
employment or
tenure first on cbs this morning
best-selling author that's ta-nehisi
coates joins us to discuss the 10-year
controversy
and the larger debate about the 16-19
project
and how we teach u.s history in this
country good morning to you tonight
coats it's always good to have you here
i know that you know nicole hannah jones
very well
and i know you've been talking to her
and you don't want to betray any
confidence
any confidential conversations that
you've had but i'm very curious about
your reaction to the controversy
good morning gail i'm sorry i can't be
in the studio with you yeah me too i
can't wait
[Laughter]
um you know my reaction is that uh while
on the one hand this is clearly about uh
nicole
who is uh to my mind among if not the
most decorated journalists in our
profession and how she was treated down
at unc but there is a much bigger debate
that's going on here and
it is about what ideas our children
what ideas students at colleges will be
exposed to or not
the 1619 project has its detractors it
has its proponents
there's been a vigorous debate around it
as it should be that's what we want in
education that's what we want in a free
society but when i see
state legislatures when i see united
states senators when i see the president
of the united states
directing critique at it via an
executive order
when we see laws being passed actual
policy
to ban the 1619 project and ban critical
race theory and
other ideas that are deemed detrimental
um you know
i think we have a problem of a very very
different scale we've moved beyond
the realm of critique into the realm of
actual policy and i think that's a
problem yeah let's talk about critical
race theory exactly what it means and
the calls to ban
it yeah so our critical race theory is
a is a framework for understanding
american history and american life uh
and the basic premise of it starts from
the idea
that racism is endemic to to this
society now you can agree with that or
disagree with that
you know all sorts of you know
historical theories or theories that you
know can be applied
you know to the law et cetera but to ban
it i just really really want to focus on
that
you know it's not what your opinion of
it is the idea that it should be
banned from teaching at all or banned
from discussion or banned from education
or pushed out of the public square
i just you know i i think that's that's
a huge problem i think whatever your
opinion
those ideas are like you should find
that problematic there are many
notions and ideas in america that i
totally and completely disagree with
i wouldn't ban them there are a lot of
people who i think are you know are dead
dead wrong
you know i wouldn't you know move for
schools and for universities to ban a
discussion of those ideas i just think
that's a that's a that's a totally
totally different level
tanasi what do you believe the critics
of the 1619 project
are worried about well you know
i don't i don't want to speak for the
critics you know because i think that i
don't i don't
you know want to you know get into a
path where you know i'm i'm saying that
it's wrong to to criticize i mean i
think the critics have and can
speak for themselves i think the people
who are attempting to pass policy
to banish it out of the public square
are simply afraid of affair and just
accounting of american history
you know we're at a moment right now
where people are pulling down statues
and
and monuments and you know et cetera and
we're having a much much broader
reconsideration of what the history of
this country
is you know and there's some hard
questions to be asked why is it that
fences in the state of tennessee
there are more statues of nathan bedford
forest one of the founders of the ku
klux klan
then all three presidents born in
tennessee put together
how can that be true what's going on you
know and so i i think like we're having
this broader conversation right now
that um really scares a lot of people uh
thanks for joining us
ashley here so i just want to know um
what do you hope that americans will
take away from this controversy
i hope they will they will they will
come to understand that no matter how
discomforting
an idea is no matter how you know
an idea makes you feel or whatever when
you're
uh when you see the state using policy
to remove
those notions from the public square um
you you've got a problem of a different
order again i just want to be really
really clear you don't have to agree
with nicole
you don't agree with me you don't have
to agree with with anybody but when you
see the president of the united states
directing an executive order uh towards
a journalistic project you should be
afraid
and i as a journalist you know it's the
only thing that i can think that you
know it could easily be me any of us
could be could be next when you see the
state
moving to ban all sorts of discussions
yeah that was former president trump you
were speaking of but i want to go back
to nicole hannah jones who
at the time unc called her one of the
country's leading voices in journalism
at the top of her field her supporters
say listen
her credentials are impeccable so is her
work ethic so how does she go from that
to now we're not sure about tenure
which by the way unc is saying we have
not denied tenure
that is not what's happening here
well i mean no decision is is
effectively a denial
uh you know nicole went through all of
the many many steps for tenure
uh the vote was you know and this is
according to the word of the board of
trustees it was brought before them and
they just declined to
to vote on it so i mean i don't know how
that's that's any better
you know i i do want to say that you
know this morning uh we we have a letter
that we're delivering to
to unc uh and the the uh signees you
know just give a broad range of how much
support there is
for open dialogue and open debate we
have everybody from chris paul
to cornell west to amy cheryl there is a
broad
broad broad concern here something
has gone deeply wrong this if this is
the letter that's gone live on the root
it has i mean it looks like it has
hundreds of signatures and
and the the line that strikes uh me here
is that few single works
have been threatened with more
restrictions than the 1619 project
yeah i mean look i've you know uh
certainly
tried to make a career writing things
that provoked conversation you know
i have never ever written anything that
drew the ire of 22
united states senators they drew the eye
of multiple attorneys generals they drew
the eye of the state of texas they drew
to ireland
nicole's home state of iowa we i'm sorry
we're going to run out of time but we're
all watching we thank you for your
time this morning we'll be right back
thanks for having me on
welcome